[applaudissements]
[musique]
Oh, je n'ai jamais
Au propos de vous
Oh, je suis sur le point de la rattraper, et son amant est sur le point de me rattraper
Mouchk
Au propos de vous
Elle voulait la suivre et j'étais son amant
[musique]
Faire
Compte les gens du quartier et entoure l'actualité avec une grande intensité, ô Bashd
C'est si dur de sortir et de voir ce qui m'est arrivé toute ma vie
Mashima et Shet
Et
Que va-t-il lui arriver, où est son amant ?
À propos de Yo Yo
[musique]
Oui
Oh, maman, elle est avec moi, où es-tu ?
Comme tu le dis, dis-le
Dis-moi, imagine-le
[musique]
Dire
H
Et voilà, vois quelqu'un qui tient à toi, qui tient à toi, qui te protège
J'ai choisi des gens et on m'a dit qu'ils m'accompagneraient
Je n'ai jamais été avec toi
Et il t'a serré fort
Oh, je veux que tu la suives, et je suis son amant
Je ne t'ai jamais vu avec moi
C'est sur le point d'arriver
Vous êtes sur le point de la rattraper ainsi que son amant
[musique]
À propos
Oh, travaille avec moi et vois où tu en es
Tu dis, dis
Dis-moi, j'en ai une vidéo, et c'est parti
Avec moi, je ne veux rien avoir à faire avec toi
Et elle est sur le point de rattraper son amant
D'ACCORD
mon âge
[musique]
Tu as raison et son amant
Et
[musique]
Merci merci